ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo depa vj show
per favore non ho più pallida idea
io so cosa che fa la moglie figo la
situazione è questa
questa qua se vuoi rendetevi conto della
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono fa vj sono in un carrello di
merda e sai quanto mi fa male quando
batte il doc se il nostro pratici ed
assai potere dietro c'è una macchina che
si deve vendere facciamo passare salve
al ven
salve salve da chi cazzo penso alla
gente che potresti per favore mi
vergogno c'è la gente c'è un ragazzo di
un carrello e lo vendo per 50 centesimi
per niente 21 di interessi vergogno
altri otto devi sapere una cosa di me
sono un ragazzo timido io mi vergogno
nel ritiro così albè tutto a posto
di certo alla fine il carrello facciamo
un servizio self un profumo dare ogni
giorno dietro che possa non piacere
conoscere io comunque così le persone
dunque di non ci credo è un grande e
così che io
i dialoghi con le ragazze si fanno così
vedete come funziona c'è un unicorno
sarà un altro di quei ragazzi perché
[Applauso]
dicono che porti sfiga per l'ombra
elencata
[Musica]
un po freddo prende una giacca di
lorenzo lorenzo non posso prendere la
giacca la tua per riuscire grazie o bana
raga andiamo a farci salti fuori dalle
scuole con la giacca di fa vj e rai
no ma cagato addosso un piccione
ma io assistevo tutto zio perché ciò la
giacca di parigi lei può fare tutto ai
superpoteri
sarà contento fari jasper vado io su di
lui fa mentre prima mente loren e no c'è
un problema chiamate ad un piccione
ma è vero non agisce passaggio ma si
sciolgono gara stato il voler un operaio
non e yogurt
ok ragazzi invece avete presente i posti
dove vai a mangiare e per fare
l'ordinazione bisogna lasciare proprio
il nome che quando l'ordine è pronto ti
chiamano dall'altoparlante tu vai a
ritirare quello che hai ordinato gli
amici hanno scritto al posto del mio
nome
questo è stata bellissima
ora di pranzo un momento molto aspettato
dai ragazzi ma [ __ ] a dos quanto
il mezzo vale li sono mangiati non ti fa
vincere quindi lo su ebay non è che
incredibile ma è buono adesso mi fa
vedere adesso mi fa schifo non lo maggio
cioè la musica tu pure
[Musica]
dai zio la fame scarpa la famiglia ha
detto e fatto per volare di questa demo
ma l'obiezione che non vuole toccare per
terra col pierrey il tar turismo
ingiusto panino io basta io me la prendo
e rapidi ma che temi che mi ha lasciato
degli amici allora funziona così via io
ci ho paura degli scarichi elettrici si
tiene questa cosa in mano il primo che
schiaccia avrà in tasca
[Musica]
[Applauso]
bene
beh
d'amico no no quest uomo dignitoso e non
avendo la videocamera portato un
carrello in casa mia a vijay non va a
far la spesa e la spesa che va da pavia
vuole vincere sulla ruota del carrello
giuro ho visto tutto era mia vita ho
visto robe ma carrelli casomai non poté
fare un giro per casa se accetti portati
a uscire è quindi ragazzi vero che video
vi sia piaciuto è stato non ho potuto
mettere un sacco di cose perché sto
preparando una cosa epica quindi niente
non posso far vedere di più però che vi
do vi sia piaciuto e cosa in questo
momento è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook con video trovate nella
pattumiera
iscrivetevi ci rivediamo a un prossimo
video bella ragazza
buona questa tappa